what is going on with the say almost a
new house Rob Kardashian's life is
completely different this according to a
source the 31 year old reality star has
been making major changes in his life in
terms of his health and his relationship
with his family I love that a source
tells ET rob has lost around 30 to 50
pounds since taking a step back from the
spotlight after his very public split
from ex-fiance blac Chyna in July 2017
source tells ET Rob's life is completely
different now and he has been working
hard to get it back on track for the
sake of his one-year-old daughter dream
Rob got his health under control by
working with professionals exercising
and eating well the source says quote
he's got his priorities in check first
and foremost he is there for dream and
he knows that to do so he needs to be
healthy to be a good dad
although Rob was in a dark place after
his split from China the two have since
mended their co-parenting relationship
we're all vote getting out of the
spotlight was so important for Rob he
needed to completely change his life
things were spiraling out of control for
him and his health and relationships
were suffering he needed to refocus the
source adds Rob has been spending a lot
of time with his family and all the
cousins dream and Rob's sister's kids
are very close earlier this month Khloe
posted an adorable photo of the little
ones having a cupcake party for her
daughter trues 6-month birthday
you